hello everyone welcome to this demo
in this demo we are going to talk about
it how exactly we can do the
installation of
maven on the mac operating system so
here we are going to talk about that how
we can do for a specific setup where we
can do
for the installation of maven in a mac
operating system
so let's see so there are two ways of
doing the installation here first is
through the
brew executable on the mac now this brew
utility on mac is just like
apt or yum utility which is present in
most of the environments or
most of the platforms here but here we
are using this brew to do the
installation of maven on the mac
operating system and again this next one
is just in
a particular mechanism where you should
be able to have these setup like you can
download the binaries from the apache
website
and then you can export the m2
underscore home and the path variable so
that you can
start using the maven executable so
we'll talk about these things and
we'll see that how exactly we can go for
this setup so let's log in uh to a
particular
machine or mac operating system so where
we will be able to do all this activity
so this is the mac system which we have
here now in this one what we are going
to do is that we are going to open the
terminal
so we are going to open a terminal here
so this is my terminal
so usually in mac you don't require any
other mechanism so the
inbuilt terminal is more than sufficient
for doing this stuff because
it's similar to a linux based platform
here so i'm going to run the command
here so first of all i'll just double
check that if my brew executable is
working fine
so i'll just run the brew help command
to see that uh if my brew is
working fine as such over here in this
one now i have the
command called brew install so that is
the command which we need to use
now in this one we have to actually give
the specific
package which we want to install so we
will say like brew install maven
so it will download the uh specific
executables on the system
from the website it will download the
maven executables
so it will take some time but ultimately
it's trying to download it under the
particular tar file so you can see here
that it's
downloading a 3.6.3 tar file over here
so i can see that the installation is
done so the three point six point three
version should be installed over here
so when i do like maven uh mvn under uh
hyphen iphone version over here
so you can see that the uh 3.6.3 version
is deployed as such over here
now this is something which is done with
the purely command over here called brew
which really helps us to do any kind of
package installations
not only maven other packages also can
be installed pretty much with the help
of this executable
now in order to see the manual stuff
what we really need to do is that we
need to actually
clean this uh specific installation so
that i should i will be able to show you
the manual installation also over here
so what i'm going to do is that i'm
going to run the command called
brew uninstall maven so that
the maven should be removed from your
system so
we are just trying to remove the maven
from here and you can see that the maven
executable
is not working as such over here so
which means that the maven is
uninstalled in this case
but why i have uninstalled here so that
i should be able to
go ahead and download some custom maven
over here in this one
so i have opened the browser here so
i'll go for the maven
executable so we'll go for maven
download so that
we should be able to download a specific
the
executable here so i'm going for this
directory so here uh 3.6.3 version same
is available
here so i'm going to download the bin.gz
which was uh the file we have so
this is also a kind of a linux platform
right so
that's the reason why here the tar file
should work perfectly fine
so here i'm going to the opt directory
where we can have all the optionals
related packages so if it is not there
so i can create a directory called
slash opt so i can
log in with
root so if you don't have the root
access so you can go for the
applications
in the applications you can actually
create a directory called maven
so here i can go for me one
yeah so here we will be
downloading the var file here so the uh
tar.ganji file we are downloading over
here so i'll
give the path here so once the var file
or wkate command i am using to do the
installation but
sometimes the wwk is not available so i
can go for the
brew install wget also if that package
is available on preview the installation
will be done
so we'll try to do the installation
using grab locate so that we will be
able to get a tar file generated
or downloaded there are other ways also
you can download it
from the browser also yeah you can go to
the browser and
here you can actually click and download
it and then you can transfer it locally
to this uh a specific directory also so
both the possibilities are there
but i'm just trying to download the
delegate command so that it will be easy
for me to do the setup and
to do the download over here so i'm
going to run the same command again
so it will download the tar file so this
is the tar file which is available over
here so i'm going to
extract it over here
so once the extraction is done so i'm
going to rename it like to apache
maven so that i should not have any kind
of versioning or these kind of
parameters over here and the apache
daughter
maven hyphen this star file i'm trying
to remove as such over here
so this is what i have got as an end
result over here
now this is the current directory in
which i have these uh applications and
these setups
going forward over here so if i run the
mvn hyphen fn version command
so that will not be giving me any kind
of output over here because
still i have extracted the tar file but
that is not the activity is not complete
i have to exactly set up some
environment variables
so that i should be able to run this mvn
command so what i really need to do
over here is that we have to export
certain variables
application slash maven
apache ma1 so this is the home directory
which i'm trying to configure over here
and then next thing is that path
variable so i'm going to
have we are going to carry the path
variable
with the folder so i'm going to have the
folder structure here
so the bin directory we have to provide
so i'm going to
copy here and paste
and then i'm concatenated with the bin
here so now
my environment variables are established
so
my mvn hyphen iphone version command as
you can see here
is that you know it's being picked up
over here but it's saying that the
particular
java runtime is not available so i can
go for java
view install java so that should be
enough there to install a java package
there so
you can see that it says that it's
already installed so and up to date so
that's the reason why it's not able to
do the installation so i'm going to
reinstall
open jdk
because what happens that when we do the
installation some environment variables
related to java
should be formatted or should be
extracted over here right
so as you can see that uh here it's
saying that if you want to really use
the
executable of java you have to
concatenate the path like this
so let's run that and uh then we can see
that
the particular executable of java will
also be find out over here so java
hyphen version showing that yes it's
available there
and now my command
should be able to show me that yes it's
working fine the gdk was
already installed but the problem with
that is that since
it's installed into a particular
location so you have to actually
override your path value so that you
should be able to see in that directory
and find out the java executable
so that i have got by doing the
installation i got the command over
there
in the output saying that this is the
installation which is done and now you
just have to extract or you have to just
you know put that bar directory into the
specified
uh path variable and that's how you got
the maven and java both command lines
working over here
so this is how you will be doing the
maven installations all together
how the overall installation of maven
and the jdk
really works on mac operating system so
that's it for this demo thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here